Okay, one answer, and the actual way this happens, is
that the cell could make a copy just of the sequence
that it needs for the current recipe it's making, and
bring it to the cytoplasm to be turned into protein. Just
imagine for a second that we actually make a tiny
copy, just of this little piece of the chromosome here. Because
that's the information we're interested in. And then we bring
it out of the nucleus into the cytoplasm. And now we
have access to these ribosomes that can use the
information to build from. Now there might be other ways
you've thought of to do this. Like someone came up
with a way where, like a piece of the nucleus
might break off into the cytoplasm carrying DNA directly
to the ribosomes. Another possible explanation you could have come
up with is that there's another special compartment that could
house both DNA and ribosomes so they have to be
trafficked there or taken there together. Or
maybe you thought of something even more unique.
But the way a cell solves the problem is that it makes copies of the
information that it needs to build the protein that it wants at that time, and
it takes these copies into the cytoplasm.
To actually be turned into protein by ribosomes.